that the world puts us in a position
like that but now we have to make some
further decisions so they'll be made
fairly soon we are not going to engage
in the Civil War itself and in the worst
interest of not just the Chemical
Weapons Convention but of civilization
itself President Trump and defense
secretary mattis setting the stage for
what looks like an imminent military
strike in Syria but exactly when and how
big let's bring in our panel
Steve Hayes of the Weekly Standard Susan
page from USA Today and Charles heard of
The Washington Times the president
secretary mattis and top national
security officials all met at the White
House today we're told that secretary
mattis presented the president with
various options Steve what are you
hearing from your sources about the
timing and scope of whatever the US
response is gonna be well nobody knows
right I mean in part because even if
James Madison a at a particular battle
planner gave the president a series of
options and the president settles on one
today it's unclear that that will be the
option that the president settles on
tomorrow
if you think about where we were eight
days ago the president United States had
his national security team meeting with
him at the White House saying I want to
end US involvement in Syria in 48 hours
everybody out 48 hours his team pushed
back against that gave the president
other options suggest that we would see
chaos if that's what we tried to do so
that it was impossible but we'd see
chaos with a precipitous withdrawal and
just a matter of days later the
president is talking publicly about
deepening US involvement in Syria in a
pretty serious way and making tweeting
threats to Russia the problem here is
there is no serious strategy there's no
serious strategy so to the questions you
posed at the beginning when how big I
would add to what end what's the
objective well along these lines of a
kind of uncertain path yesterday the
president tweeted and we reported on it
last night
Russia get ready the missiles will quote
will be coming today he put out this
tweet never said when an attack on Syria
would take place could be very
not so soon at all and that led to this
exchange between the Democratic and
Republican leaders in the house of
course the president says maybe I will
maybe I won't I'll let you know in 24
hours 48 hours I think you're wrong to
suggest that he's dead during he is
being deliberate and he is going through
all of the options and he's consulting
our allies that's what you want
presidents to do in moments like this
Susan I I think it's fair to say that
the run-up has been bumpy but isn't the
president too far down this road now to
call off a military strike whenever it
happens yes I think that's right I think
he so clearly has said that he will
respond militarily to the terrible
pictures of the use of chemical weapons
that it would be a bigger walk back than
President Obama when he decided not to
go ahead and after Syria crust hits his
red line with with action and that was
something of course Trump was very
critical of at the time it's been
critical since so yes I think he will
react I think the question is what does
he do after the military strikes take
place does this signal a longer-term
commitment unlike what he said last week
and also does it get us engaged in a
real military confrontation with Russia
which would have all kinds of perils and
then there was defense secretary mattis
telling a congressional committee today
that he intends to see international
chemical weapons inspectors arrived in
Syria which is supposed to happen this
weekend and that raises the question of
delay charlie because you you've got to
know I mean this happened what several
days ago already and the president
talked about 24 hours 48 hours were well
past that deadline already and while
delay consideration whatever you want to
call it deliberation is going on you've
got to know the Russians and the
Iranians and the Syrians are busy hiding
any assets that they think they can hide
or absolutely and this raises the real
the all those questions about how deeply
involved are we going to get how
involved are we going to get in terms of
of having boots on the ground for
example if it actually comes to that and
I don't represent it in a tough
situation because obviously we've been
down this path before we know what Trump
Trump is bah as sent missiles in this
area for this very infraction before but
it's not what he got elected for and and
what he got elected for he got elected
on a lot of promises to get to disengage
from things like this and I think it's a
real I think it's a real problem for him
in terms of the people that support him
the other thing is that you know we've
heard about the the we've heard talk
about the the helicopter that apparently
dropped the the poison the gas that was
was tracked and that's how we feel
fairly certain that it was in fact the
Assad regime but you know we all
remember the slam dunk thing we all
remember you know we don't have the
greatest track record of getting
involved in these places and and you
know I think that when you couple all
that together
it raises real questions about whether
we whether we should be doing anything
over there you really have questions
about one that Assad was responsible and
two I think we think we've had a pretty
bad track record getting involved in
things like this and it is what Donald
Trump absolutely ran his campaign
against this sort of involvement and I
think it's I think he has to be careful
do that got about a minute your response
to that
but he also ran his campaign on keeping
America safe and I think you're right I
mean Donald Trump clearly ran against
military adventurism and and even
humanitarian intervention which is
what's the justification to use the last
time he sent but we attacked in Syria
the bigger question is is in part on the
ISIS case that the administration is
making the administration is saying and
Trump said if just Monday at his
briefing with military leaders basically
Isis is wiped out they don't have any
territory therefore they're not really a
threat that's been the consistent case
from the administration it is not true
that's not true
there are there are lots of Isis
fighters still in Syria pockets of them
numbering potentially as many as 10 to
15,000
hottests in country still we have not
wiped out Isis and I'm worried that the
administration is making the same kind
of mistakes giving a false sense of
security to the American people that the
Obama administration made on both Isis
and al-qaeda all right we are gonna have
to take a break here I have a feeling
we'll be talking about this for a few
days and potentially into the weekend
and next week